about 18 months ago i made a trip
uh up to eugene oregon back when we
do such things
[Music]
i went to go see a guy named mark
frommeyer he's
the founder and ceo of a company called
arkamoto
which makes this very cool and got a
different
electric vehicle they call it a fun
utility vehicle
a fun it's super fun to drive
and i took it all around eugene
the company after this really long
struggle had started to hit its stride
its manufacturing plant
was up and running they knocked out the
first hundred vehicles and started
delivering them all up and down
the west coast of the united states and
then of course
the coronavirus came along and slowed
everything down for them
but if there's a bright spot in any of
this at least
for arcimoto it's that their vehicles
have turned out to be
really useful during the pandemic and
maybe to have opened up some new
opportunities
for the company and so with that
let us head up to eugene and and mark's
house
and check in on arkamoto
[Music]
aha i get to take a tour of your house
one of the rare perks of doing this we
cleaned up the kitchen just for you
this is the one you've had since the
start this is vin
vin number zero i don't know if you can
read that i don't know if this is
too awkward but can you sort of flip
your screen around so that somebody
who's never seen one of these before
can take a peek at the console so you
got the it's a a fairly bare-bones
screen shows your state of charge the
phone
you put your your so if you want
navigation you just have it on your
phone right here in the middle of the
handlebars
and then all your controls are on your
hands so
you've got it really the vehicle is i
think that combination of having
something that's really really fun
to drive and is is practical for daily
trips
and at the same time makes a meaningful
statement about sustainability
i think the red man this is sweet ride
um
but i gotta assume you guys have been
struggling a little bit to get some of
the new ones
that you've made out to customers well
we've been doing some kind of
crazy uh california road trips we the
the one way we figured out we could do
deliveries uh just
for some very key ones was we got a got
a
a motor home we're loading up the very
first delivery outside of arcimoto for
commercial purposes
we've enclosed our covid bubble
on the road one nice thing about driving
in california in the middle of a
pandemic is
it's the very first time i've ever seen
google maps be
all green it is one of the only nice
things
to come out of this get all those gas
cars off the road
hey mark what's up buddy i just want to
let you know how much i am enjoying my
amazing fuv arca moto
it is an absolute blast how did this
stuff with mark wahlberg even come up he
was actually he's a business partner of
one of our
our key investors he you know he used to
ride motorcycles
uh but then has kids and decided that
was not a not a wise idea
so i the last time i saw you in person
uh it was
probably like 18 months ago and you guys
have been
on this long journey uh you'd finally
got the factory
up and running and hit your stride uh
you know what what's been the story of
the last 18 months for arcimoto
we've now been in production for a
little bit less than a year
and we've we've put more than 100
production
fuvs on the road uh we have
launched our pilots of the rapid
responder which is our
our vehicle for emergency services law
enforcement
campus security and the deliberator
which is
our vehicle for for last mile delivery
we put those pilots on the road in march
and then of course
um we're having this discussion from our
houses because we're
we're in the middle of a pandemic
[Music]
and that has been um you know if you
think of
the the production hell of beginning the
scaling process and then add in
a global pandemic that has disrupted
supply chains
made our own manufacturing processes
we've really had to rethink
how we space people out within the
facility all of that's been going on
at the same time that i think are the
the vehicles that we're building
uh have have become if anything more
relevant
to to to the world that we're facing
what's
been your like personal experience
through the pandemic because i would
think
it's got to be incredibly frustrating
you get the the company to this good
point you get the manufacturing line
humming the customers are starting to
get their deliveries and then and then
this this crisis
sets in how have you coped with that i
think the frustrating part for me is
just that we have
a lot of customers who've been waiting
for a very long time to get their
arcimotos
and we've had to you know hold off on
delivering them and finishing them and
and so on um
if anything if this venture has taught
me anything it is
some measure of patience uh i've been at
it for almost 13 years
uh and so while it that has been a
frustration
i think the the the sort of silver
lining of it
at least for the company is to have a
chance
to really focus on what it takes to get
to scale
and that's that's important for us
really well for for every reason but
primarily if we actually want to
succeed in our mission which is to make
a meaningful impact
on climate change and transportation
emissions
we've got to make a lot of these things
we're shooting for a production rate of
50 000 vehicles a year
in 24 months that's what takes us from
the realm of sort of a boutique
uh niche vehicle provider to really
providing a mass market solution and so
taking the time to figure that out while
the world is
is sort of shut down is a good use of
time
one of the crazier things during the
pandemic has been that the the stock
market's been going up uh
tesla in particular has basically
been going to the moon and its stock is
sort of borderline ridiculous right now
the bull market in tesla
it's real and it's spectacular it's gone
from 361 dollars to almost
1800. tesla could really be stock of the
month in stock of the year
you have to kind of decide for yourself
whether this is is rational
or not um but without doubt the
the rise of tesla has had this knock-on
effect of making all the
electric vehicle makers stocks shoot up
as well
and i was just kind of curious what you
make of all this
almost every so if you look at the
basket of stocks
that we're in every everyone from neo to
uh nicola to solo to
workhorse they've all just you know gone
right up the hockey stick
and i think that is indicative of a few
things one
is is that this is the first time for
some time for some people in their
lifetimes where they've
seen what clean skies look like and the
the electric vehicle is what
gets us there from a transportation
standpoint and
i think also the the ideas around
how we're going to transport ourselves
have changed you know
when when's the next time you plan to
jump on a plane
when's the next time you play people are
are working from home
they're so your need to commute long
distance your need to fly long distance
has gone away largely and instead it's
all about
how can i enjoy my local area my local
community
get to the grocery store go out in in
the in the country for a ride or
whatever
i i think if the pandemic if i had one
take away from it
uh it is that it for me it fundamentally
dispelled the notion that people can't
change
everything changed in the span of a very
short period of time
once people realized that there was a
grave threat
and what that actually really gives me
hope
that when people see the enormity of the
threat
posed by climate change that we will
begin
making the big steps that we need to
make together
in order to address the problem
you're a busy guy and so you know very
busy in addition to all the
electric vehicle work um i mean you've
been working on like a new
sort of voting system for a while now
right so i
had a front row seat to the political
process i was actually
born into my dad's very first campaign
for the state legislature
and then he went on to hold statewide
office dad
would be a gay governor dave bronmeyer
a lot of people really like him and what
became really clear to me over time
is that we have a super broken political
system what i found is that there's
there's a little bug
in how we vote that leads to the
polarization that we see
and that bug is that in every election
we're limited to a single choice so what
star voting
aims to do is is fix that bug
by giving an equally weighted vote to
all the voters
it shifts the choice from one choice
per office to actually letting you have
an opinion a zero to five star
opinion on every candidate for a
particular office
i mean can you give me just like the
bare bone basics on on how
this works and what stars stands for so
so star is an acronym because it
represents
the ubiquitous five-star you know zero
stars bad
five stars good rating that we're all
familiar with
from everything from apps to amazon but
the the acronym means score
then automatic runoff all the scores get
added up
the two candidates who scored the most
over
all the people those are the finalists
and then your vote
simply goes to whichever one of those
two you gave a higher score
okay so so if there's like if there's
like six candidates i can go in
if i want i could do it just like a
regular election and just give my
favorite five and and leave everyone
zero or
i could go in give my favorite five and
then maybe i kind of like the policies
of two or the other people
i could actually like give them like a
four star or three star or something in
between
you could go five four four one zero
it's totally sort of backward compatible
with how we vote now
if you're like ah that's you know too
complicated you just give your one favor
to five and move on that's a totally
valid vote
but if you have an opinion about more
than one candidate running
you can express it to whatever level of
support you want to give a candidate you
can do that where have we
seen it in practice so far it was used
for the very first time
in a statewide political election here
in oregon this year
almost every single person who was able
to get into the system
used it voters when given the
opportunity to have a more nuanced
viewpoint on the outcome actually do use
that capability
and is it is it better suited for any
particular kind
of election or is this something you
think is universal and you guys would
like to see it
be used in presidential elections dog
catcher to president
but we think it's going to bring
immediate benefit at whatever level of
government it's used
and ultimately the goal is to heal the
political divide
that we face as a as a people two
polarized parties
each of which are aggregations of
special interests
trying to get to 50 plus one because and
that's what
pockets things that should not be
political issues
like the work to address climate change
should not be a political issue racial
justice should not be a political issue
but they end up getting loaded into
one or the other party where each party
sort of has to oppose
the position that the other party is
taking we are not
a polarized people we have a polarizing
process
that is driving a wedge through the
country
uh and i think it's it to our great
peril that that's the case
you